some states are taking action against
the new federal tax law to make sure as
many Americans as possible receive
benefits the new tax law puts a $10,000
cap on state and local deductions
previously there was no limit for states
and Washington DC you have the highest
average deduction claims Alex Wagner
spoke with one family in New Jersey
about the financial uncertainty good
morning Alex good morning 30% of
Americans itemize their deductions but
part of Republicans tax reform now
limits the amount that can be deducted
that may mean higher taxes and a lot of
confusion for some families there's
times where you know yes we do feel like
we are swimming upstream a little bit
Diana and Jeff Knight live in New
Providence New Jersey with their three
children there you go with major changes
to the tax code including a new limit on
state and local tax or salt deductions
they worry about their long term
financial security in some regards we
make less now than we made three years
ago when there's the potential for more
money to be leaving your pocket you know
obviously that is gonna raise concern
for you the knight family's annual
deduction claims are about $18,000 near
the New Jersey state average the kids
are getting bigger we'd love to do an
addition on the house because we need
space if we consider expanding on the
house then that also means that our
property taxes would increase with the
cap on salt deductions millions of
Americans may end up seeing a tax
increase and lawmakers are considering
different ways to help them New York
will pay an additional 14 billion in New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo is
considering revamping payroll taxes to
help offset the burden on individual
taxpayers one plan with lower wages and
employers would then pay the income
difference to the state as a payroll tax
on the employees behalf a bill being
proposed in California would allow
taxpayers to make charitable donations
to a specific fund in exchange for an 85
percent tax credit Georgetown Law
Professor Brian galley says that option
might work in Washington DC where the
annual average deduction claim is more
than sixteen thousand dollars a year if
you would
able to deduct 16000 and the new federal
cap only allows you to deduct an you
would donate six the Trump
administration says states should give
their own tax cuts instead of working
around federal tax law but for many of
these states slashing taxes is not an
option New Jersey for example is already
more than 100 billion dollars in debt
OMG for the moment families like the
Knights must wait there's a contention
that this is gonna be a great thing for
everybody hopefully it won't be too much
of a hit and perhaps we could benefit
but down the line I'm not so sure about
that
part of California's proposal has been
passed by the state Senate and is
awaiting a vote by the state assembly
and New York New Jersey and Connecticut
are planning to sue the federal
government over the new cap it is not a
coincidence that a lot of these states
that may be hardest hit are blue coastal
states that did not go for Donald Trump
yeah
really interesting it's not over it is
not over a lot of development on the tax
array thank you Alex thanks guys